I need to know this is not your last
season please tell us you're coming back
to dancing with the stars I don't think
so well it looks like Max meant it he
will be returning for the new season of
Dancing with the Stars and he's not the
only one I'm Denny directo and this is
trending on TV now the ballroom
bombshell was dropped wednesday on Good
Morning America karina smirnoff Tony
Dovolani Cheryl Burke and Val
Chmerkovskiy Max's younger brother were
on hand to reveal who will be back
besides the four of them other fan
favorites like Mark Ballas peta
murgatroyd and five-time winner Derek
hub will hit the dance floor for season
19 you know I'm excited to be part of
the show it's amazing so who's out
Sharna Burgess and Sasha Farber for
starters Tristan MacManus Henry pilaf
Cove and Tyne Stecklein won't return
either newcomers will include Artem
Chigvintsev who happens to be judged
Karianna Navas X key emotes FA and so
you think you can dance all starr
allison holker the celebrities joining
the cast will be announced September
fourth Tom Bergeron and Erin Andrews
will continue as host when the show
returns on ABC September 15